Selena Gomez's secret kidney transplant
the 25 year old opening up about her
latest health crisis and introducing us
to the friend who helped save her life
holding hands with the best friend who
gave Selena the gift of life Gomez
revealed she went into kidney failure
and received a transplant 29 year old
actress francia raisa was the one who
donated her organ it is speculated the
surgery happened in May and this image
shows the scar which now stretches over
most of Selena's torso the singer says
the transplant was a result of her
ongoing battle with lupus
[Music]
francy and selina met a decade ago a
source close to Aissa tells ET that none
of Selena's family was a kidney match
and quote it didn't take any convincing
to get Francia to see if she was a match
and of course she was lupus is a chronic
disease which attacks the body's immune
system a kidneys when Selena went public
with her diagnosis in 2015 a slew of
online trolls were targeting her body
swelling and weight gain can be a side
effect of kidney disease you have
brilliantly handled some nasty body
shamers this year well you know because
I felt like there was this period well I
guess it still was kind of happening
where it's a build you up to knock you
down kind of thing I only know how to be
myself Selena was back to work today in
Manhattan looking happy and healthy on
the set of an untitled Woody Allen film
her boyfriend The Weeknd has reportedly
been by Salinas I threw out her health
crisis one month before the surgery is
said to have taken place she told us how
it is her mission to empower fans by
being so open I always hope that the
people I'm involved with her or support
me can just kind of spread love you know
it's hard